each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my pleasure to welcome James Nobu
from university of wellington new
zealand most of you know James for his
ambition to control aliasing in doctrine
or languages through ownership systems
and ownership types and so on but today
is not actually going to talk about that
that's amazing so instead we're going to
hear about how to strip down object
oriole anguishes to their essence
hopefully in in in Greece yeah sure
thanks for that matter it's nice to be
here and to all my listeners around the
world hello and it's nice that we're
quite a small group this is my line for
being bitter and twisted that there's
three other seminars on at the same time
um the nice thing is is that with being
a small group we can be interactive so
I've got a bunch of slides but I'm more
than happy to take questions and you
know abuse and comments and suggestions
and we'll see how we go so what's this
project and why are we doing it why are
we thinking now about a new object
oriented programming language and you
know the story behind this is that sort
of the three of us with with a bunch of
other people I don't have all the names
on the slides because there seemed to be
more people who at least don't think
this is completely daft idea we're
having a discussion that e coupe in
Slovenia about nine months ago and we
were all saying well we've week teaching
Java and you know it's okay and we were
invested in it we've got a lot of
teaching materials and it tutors
everybody knows this do we want to be
doing that in 2020 in substance is Java
the best thing we can really do for
introducing perhaps that the
universities for the rest of us students
to programming and in 10 years time do
we think that will be the case because
in 2015 job is going to be 20 years old
happy birthday hopefully the state of
the art has advanced and I mean in some
ways you can see this in in Java and in
NN c sharp because well you know java's
now got
generic types important new advanced and
computer science in the last 20 years or
so it's now got that that's good lambda
expressions there's a whole bunch of
stuff big numbs you great big decimal
and I presume C sharp has all these
things and so the state of the art has
advanced and in some sense Java and C
sharp have actually advanced along with
it the catch is that from a professional
programming point of view this bit here
is important new languages are bringing
new ideas so if you like you can write
in Java or or even more so in c-sharp
programs that are structured and use all
kinds of constructs that you know you
couldn't do it in java version 1.0 the
language the programs could look
completely different but of course those
Java 1 point 0 programs are still going
to be quite legal in the Java of today
and the same thing is C sharp across the
range the catch is that when the new
language is bringing good ideas or the
old languages are updated to include
them we'll still got all the old ideas
and again this is probably strictly to a
strictly truer of Java than it is of
something like C sharp because well c
sharp had the advantage of hindsight by
looking back at java and so what i think
is this kind of compatibility problem
while it's important professionals is it
difficulty for us when we want to teach
we want to teach programming ideally at
universities we don't really want to
teach a particular language although i
don't think there's any way to teach
someone to be a program unless unless
they learn through what you do with them
and come out as being a competent
programmer in at least one programming
language preferably more than one
preferably languages that are different
the point is what i'm using fred
Brooks's dichotomy between the essential
differences are things that make
programming really hard and the
accidental difficulties the stuff that
our technology puts in the way we find
these accidental difficulties things we
know how to do better just take a lot of
time so say in our first year course in
theory we have 36 lecture hours in front
of students and students do labs and
students do tutorials and other things
but that gives us roughly 36 topics we
can talk about
now one of those topics has to be the
welcome everybody to the course and then
another you know and then another one
has to be here's what's in the exam and
another one's the terms test so maybe in
a half semester you've got 30 topics you
can talk about all right so in Java one
of those has to be the difference
between int and integer and float and
double okay in order to make almost
anything happened with the any AP ice in
Java you have to explain to students
what the difference between float and
double and inches now is this important
for programmers to know yes it is is
this something that really has to be
taught right at the beginning of
teaching people to program I don't think
so if you want to teach people how a
Java or a co-op program is evaluated you
know it's welcome to overloading I
really like overloading and in my terms
test I really like overloading because
in my terms tests I can always find
really really difficult problems for
students to evaluate you know a
debugging problem what will this code do
you know if I've got this thing in here
and then I cast it to something else and
is it revolves statically or is it
resolved dynamically and I mean were I
to switch to a c-sharp three or four
even better because we have dynamic
variables as well as static variables
and all these things would fail in
different and exciting ways at runtime I
mean it would mean that you could have
almost as much fun with method
overloading as you do with pointers but
that's another story so essentially our
project is to tackle these accidental
difficulties in programming language
design not the things that really make
it hard if you know about projects in
some ways I guess touch studio is
probably one of them their stuff like
Alice and co2 and scratch which are new
ways of in tune talk and stuff new ways
of re-envisioning what it means to
program or what it means to teach
computational thinking trying to find
ways let's tackle what makes programming
hard to learn here the idea is now um
for better or worse we think the world
still needs programmers
but we want to try and just clear out a
lot of the the craft that has been
established in these languages and you
know so basically over the next twenty
fifteen years there's space for us to
put more craft back in and then
presumably some time down the track we
repeat the whole process the other thing
is Andrew black slide points out that as
sort of academics or as programming
language designers were in the dog food
business so the user model i'll talk
about that on the next slide is for
beginning students but the people who
make the choices aren't actually the
students okay you know the people who
are going to make the choices are
hopefully experienced instructors in
programming language or faculty
committees or all these kind of things
they're the people who are actually
making these choices and that's
something again that we keep in mind so
it's not necessarily and and you'll see
some of the choices because you know
where we're academics and we also have
ideas about how things should be done
but this isn't just about what will make
it easy for someone to get things
started I suppose it's also about what
will tend to encourage people to develop
what we hope will be good habits or good
practices if they go on so what is our
use a model well as the fred brooks
latest book says every project should
have a user model so i think i was
reading it at the time when I was doing
this first or second year students in in
loc s1 or cs2 so this is an attempt at
doing another 00 language okay if you go
to CMU Bob Harper has got existential
type blog all kinds of excellent
examples why object orientation is dead
and why teach in our languages is would
be like teaching assembler at first year
etc etc we're trying to give him a run
for his money we think that there are a
lot of things that perhaps people think
are wrong with our languages that are
wrong with our languages that we tend to
use often so assuming your primary
interested in 00 the other thing we're
willing to sales but even given that is
that the asura overall approach there's
actually a whole range of different
pedagogy geez that people can use when
they're teaching so
no objects earlier objects late if
you're in this business some people
think well you can start out by teaching
objects you can start out by calling a
message on an object you have a you know
a little car and your turtle graphics
you can start doing all this stuff and
you can really get quite sophisticated
if you've got libraries before you have
to start teaching about control flow or
mutable variables and have mutable
objects but you don't have to teach
about the details of assignment or maybe
you just want to start off with control
flow and more or less teach the same
course that people have been teaching
since 1970 in Pascal here is a variable
here is an assignment is how you create
you know right the greatest common
divisor algorithm using a while loop and
using an if statement so the point here
is that this language is trying not to
buy into a whole lot of assumptions
about pedagogy and and this is different
from other other projects which we like
and admire the type scheme project sorry
the racket project that is now is with
how to design programs mathias tell us
in and his students and collaborators
they've got a very set idea about the
pedagogy its functions first it's no
mutable state first and a strict
progression through the language isn't
very nice environments to support that
but it's not just enough to say well
there are nice things in this
environment you have to say and i'm
going to teach this in the way that
Matai still ison has decided computer
science must be taught okay and we're
being a bit more relaxed than that so
static or dynamic types is another
argument here um there are lots of
people who think static types are
important they will catch errors and so
students should start with static types
there are other people increasingly
saying well you know actually it's
important that students are able to type
something in and at least make something
happen even if that thing that happens
is a crash rather than sitting there for
hours and hours trying to get the red
lines removed from under their code you
know there's always the famous story of
someone who comes in and comes to the
tutor and says well I've been working on
this for three hours and I finally got
my program to compile but it doesn't do
anything why not
I've commented the whole thing out
that's right excellent so going to
dynamic types first for some people but
certainly I know many places I mean I
think MIT starters started with Python
they moved from scheme to python quite a
lot of other places are saying well it
will do the first semester in Python and
then second semester in Java precisely
to give this kind of smoother ramp into
programming the catch is that you know
in the 30 lectures if you're lucky of
content in the first course and the 30
lectures in the content and second
course a lot of these things are going
to be okay kids well here's how used to
do it in Python and here's how you do it
in Java here's how used to do it in
Python here's how you do it in Java
there are some advantages to that I do
think people need to learn more than one
programming language but if you're
saying how do you get school kids who
increasingly and I mean this is
something touch studio is trying to
address increasingly come with with no
exposure to programming in New Zealand
the only people who even do higher
mathematics secondary school typically
of those who want to go on to become
doctors so they're not great at
mathematical thinking in my generation I
was at the computer museum last week and
yes there were all the zx80 ones and the
apple tooth wear my generation started
you'd plug these things and turn them on
you get a basic prompt I think I was
talking to UM manuel said if you want to
play a computer game you've got a book
you've got a magazine and you have to go
into the listing into your computer and
then you could save it onto a cassette
tape so there was you know even if I
didn't think about it they were at least
having to type in programs and hit run
and fix syntax errors perhaps these days
we want to make an easy ramp and then
yeah there are other approaches perhaps
you do want to start teaching some form
of functional programming first
procedural programming scripting first a
bit like object could be a bit like
objects just writing little scripts to
do things software engineering first
maybe you're going to be hard core and
say okay well the most important thing
to teach is the notion of a
pre-conditioner and if the programmer
can understand is the precondition and a
post condition then everything else will
be fine so you know is this an ambitious
goal I guess the point is to say we're
trying to cut down the things you have
to believe that you could adopt this
language and the reason is because I
think one of the one of the strengths of
languages like Java
sharp is in fact people can do all this
stuff more or less with Java or with C
sharp today and you know underlying the
one of the ideas underlying this project
I've got you know other things down here
researchers wanting an experimental
vehicle languages designers wanting a
good example I think it is important
that you know there is some sort of form
of code and it and it's going to be as
you'll see an hour or something like
Java or C sharp that people can read you
know the more we end up changing the
languages we teach the more different
computer scientists are going to be you
know across the country across various
schools I think we do need some kind of
common Latin always is a common language
that by default if you read a paper to
read a journal article you know at some
point it used to be Pascal and then it
changed to sort of C syntax and is more
or less carried on from there and you
know it might be Java it might be C++
the details aren't important the sort of
common ideas are there which means that
there's some kind of code we can expect
most people to read if one schools
mostly teaching Python and Ruby and
somebody else is teaching Haskell this
is my constellation of languages slide
in the first time a good business talk I
talk for ten minutes on the slide alone
um it's a bit of a setup you know power
and complexity and Peele one looking out
here with extreme complexity and low
power on there any PR one program is in
the room you'll probably dispute that
and you know quite why I was so mean to
ml over there I'm not sure the sort of
Java Haskell thing is sorry Java C sharp
is going along here and F sharp comes in
increasing the complexity and also
increasing the power probably not quite
as much and then in some sense on the
other side well let's ignore see Lawson
that is beast up here you've got things
like self and small talk and scheme
dynamic languages which you know yes you
are going to have to define power
oh sure I think all these languages are
touring complete with the possible
exception of PL one parent so this is
this is clearly subjective it's just my
idea of sort of how about how much the
programs can sort of do if you write
them it's not the real point of the
slightest is this if you could if you
can think of another word than power
here you know good i'm happy to have
suggestions how many work how much is so
perhaps power-to-weight is better than
just straight power how much work is the
program have to do to get some kind of
effect that
yeah in wearing one of my other hats you
know I'm enough of a sort of software
engineer that productivity could
actually mean something real and I part
I mean you're on a good point there
because I basically picked power on the
grounds that it doesn't really mean
something real and complexity as well
while um Martin a dusky does like the
metric of the number of key role pike
primarily likes the metric of the number
of key words in a language is being an
indication of its size I'm not entirely
sure that's true really what I'm trying
to get at is okay so there are these
things I mean so sorry for example I
said processing is more powerful than
Java even though processing is basically
Java because it comes in an environment
with a whole bunch of libraries for
doing processing kite type stuff so in
that sense yeah you're right how easy is
it to get get some effect what's
interesting is you start having look at
some of these things if we say take
small talk and strong talk if you don't
know what that is that's a statically
typed version of small talk or something
going quite the latest out to be typed
and you've got a ruby and a statically
typed version of Ruby um in fact there
is ironpython and pie pie pie pie
certainties is Python with added on
static types so on one level you've got
this stuff the statically typed language
is getting harder on the other side you
have languages that you know started out
as hardcore static types which are
starting to add things like dynamic okay
and if you look at some of these
languages like if you look at the
relationship between the language
biotype systems what can you say well
most of these kind of languages are
going to have a type system that you
know it has got jarnet generic types has
probably got some form of structural
type matching even mean scholar will do
that perhaps has got intersection types
and then often for Python and Ruby
there's a whole lot of weird stuff
bolted on the side for the very
incredibly strange way that the
libraries have been designed you look at
michael hicks papers he's got some
wonderful examples so I'm kind of
wondering if there is a gap and of
course have set up this slide so there
is a gap which says could you have a
language that on the one side takes the
heritage of things like Java
and C sharp and perhaps Pascal before
that in terms of doing things that are
clear and trying to make things explicit
and you know start to establish good
discipline and good habits and
programmers on the other side draw on
the heritage of these dynamic languages
about giving power with simplicity about
people being able to get started and you
know this is another argument that in
fact there might be some sort of
compromise proposal can go in here which
is what the rest of the talk is about so
getting into some actual design details
what kind of fundamentals do we have
everything is an object single message
dispatch single inheritance this notion
again imitation is the serious form of
flattery and and we think the stuff that
notorious for lice on and co in the
racket project of doing is great have
design programs etc extensible for your
libraries again also there the idea that
I mean this is something again in
teaching that is important and wide for
example I language needs some kind of
support for libraries because a lot of
what tutors and and stop members do when
they're teaching programming is set up
particular little problems or libraries
to do graphics or libraries to model
this and that that people have to
interact with and then there's this last
point which is also quite important that
Java C Python or scarlet programmers
should be able to read and I probably
should have said right as well grace
programs that if you look at this and
you think wow it's nothing but a bunch
of parenthesized expressions you're
unlikely to be able to read this stuff
if you're an instructor the dog food
problem you're less likely to be able to
adopt it but also people who've learned
to read and write grace should at least
be able to read most of these kind of
things the look of the language the feel
of language can't be too foreign from
where people are at now because you know
there is a large amount of code in the
world that is written in using a very
generalized sense the sort of language
tradition that produced these kind of
things again we're not going after the
essential difficulties of programming
we're going after the accidental
difficulties of the language in a guess
the imperative object-oriented tradition
so what does it look like the big reveal
no that's not the big reveal
no that come back to it there's a big
reveal
hmm those no semicolons right so what I
say about this slide is if I have to
explain it the projects already failed
because just explain how important is
that people can read these programs can
read and write grace code are there any
questions square one wild differences
while it looks so different
okay that is fair enough yes in while
you have to have these curly braces here
is how to do chemo yeah and you have a
loop here yes you do this thing yes you
did all of those languages have you
familiar with while the same baby about
this yes yes that is a different one of
just remarkable oh yes I could just
remark on it was there another question
yeah well why are you need to compare
the returns hope you don't need some
clothes over bubbles the type of returns
a dramatic okay number but the locals
don't have to be there no they bad so
are answering questions in the reverse
order we think it's important to declare
the type of method parameters because
that's an interface to the method these
locals are internal so what we will do
is probably local type inference here so
in that sense this is exact colon and I
think the meaning is the same as it is
in c-sharp just goes that way there is a
syntax if you want to if it's not
obvious from here you can put a type on
this you can build a pipe and also
initialize want good to want to read
relief you can at least read all the
code if you're not sure about the design
decisions I want to talk about this well
we'll talk about it we'll come to that
will come to that so what features can
we see here well these are the things we
wanted and part of the rest of the talk
is actually going to be about how so far
we've which ones we've had to give up on
more or less uncluttered code with
significant layout structural typing in
a bunch of stuff that again is in the
current generation of languages people
like basically went through long list of
features and everyone that people think
a good we put into the list it's kind of
an odd way of doing things subtyping
separated from inheritance user
definable operators that once people can
understand somehow generics allow us
both static and dynamic typing and you
know that seems to be one of the
surprisingly enough there have been
research languages that have done this I
guess there's dynamic in c-sharp I
suppose we're trying to go further than
dynamic
does with C sharp but also we're
increasingly aware we are butting up
against stuff that's really only been
done in research languages particularly
there and these various things important
for teaching minimize the number of
options you know rather than having two
or three choices about how you write a
bit of syntax will have one and maybe
that means things are a bit longer than
they need to be but people don't have to
worry about whether you write an equals
in an expression or a curly bracket and
you know a method body in a close curly
bracket minimize magic implicit implicit
conversions not throwing brick back to
any particular language but you know C
sharp sorry C++ when I was teaching that
trying to explain what on earth is going
on with copy constructors and
conversions and all this magic stuff
there's there's nothing there invoking
them that's difficult to explain I mean
it makes the great terms test once again
but the minimizing can't a shin so you
know why do you have to write public
static void main why do you have to
write class curly curly well because
it's Java and you know maybe it is
important that one of the foot one of
the very first things people learn in
order to get a computer to do something
is you know you basically have to get
your prayer in exactly the right
incantation to some strange job that
lives in the machine if I don't say
public static void main which means
almost nothing I just have to say it why
you just have to say it let's not do
that
so the basic idea is well what I now
call one true method request so like
small token sailfin and also like go we
won't overload anything okay the
computational model is we have objects a
method requests names the method and
provides the arguments and then a
dynamic dispatch in the object selects
the correspondingly name message in the
receiver okay and then the method
executing the receiver now this is basic
this is a simple story this is a story
that is true in small talk and self and
not true in lots of other languages
because you've got overloading
resolution you've got static typing
getting in the way all these kind of
things okay the idea is there'll be a
nice clear operational model with nice
clear semantics various kinds that you
know we can explain and understand what
programs are doing hopefully in a way
that people be able to understand and
follow yeah we're trying to learn not to
say message send or method call there's
a certain small talk heritage looking
under the surface that is about to raise
its head I think we're trying to method
request seems closer to what people do
in Java and these days if you say
message send half the people think
you're doing actors anyway so what a
method requests look like well you know
they look like Java you can write a
person dot print on output stream or yes
we do implicit self print on output
stream we've got operators you know x +
y greater than 0 and not cube emblem
that metrolist
so there are three syntactic forms more
or less for method requests and in fact
there are four different kinds of method
requests but that's no more than Java
and currently one less than you speak
for anybody who's counting if you want
we want to go into that we can go into
that okay what about this for loop and
this might answer some of the questions
well likes multiple we've got multiple
keyboards so you know we don't have to
do it this way but you know for do this
is seen as a single method request for
do that's on self ok that's a method
request between integers that builds a
range object yes half of them it
includes one that includes 10 I think
currently it's probably the whole row
will refer so the other issue of the
other issue is where do a weird a
collection indexing start from you won't
be here to 900 tonight I'm tempted to
say which bit of we're going to try and
make things explicit and mean what they
look like unfortunately you can't have
one of these things being a square
bracket one of these things being around
back it currently I'm sorry and you
could still read if I you could
certainly still really encourage you to
do that yeah and this this is a bit this
is that so this is the way you write a
full loop amount of our bet is we will
tell students it's it's a for loop up
just across the obviously the numbers
from 1 to 10 we don't think that there
is any more magic in writing this than
there is in writing for I gets one to 10
thought for fort number colon I 1 to 10
or PM for i equals 1 to 10 do print I we
think that we just tell people in the
first week are you just have to do it
this way it's evil magic okay except of
course well if it is evil magic that's a
lambda expression and this answers your
questions about while that you know
that's a lambda expression that's a
lambda so all the blocks in code this
one in grace they're all lambda
expressions many of these are these
strange no argument lambda expressions
which you get an imperative languages we
tend not to get in functional languages
because there's no point in calling
function if you can't can't really do
anything end was a methodist on that
one's self right yep so that mean right
I mean
so the answer is currently perhaps and
that the read the reason we're doing
this is because to get extensibility so
one of the decisions we've made for
example is we're not putting any making
any choices about concurrency into the
national language so you know where
we're up to at this point is the
sequential core and we're hoping that a
whole bunch of stuff can be added by
extensions so most the time of students
want to override this they'll probably
should get a message saying grace don't
standard pro you if then else is final
or something like that when probably
won't use the word final so you know
you'll get an error for trying to
override if but if ruston really wants
to do this and he runs his code with
something else that says by the way
we're in ruston world not standard
graceland then you'd be able to do it
and you know the other i'm not sure
where this comes up i mean the other
advantage is the claims north of
advantages you know if you want to show
how this works you can I think there's
well I think we've got blocks probably
come on a little later if you really
want to show that in this language if is
encoded roughly the way it is in the
untyped lambda calculus well you can
show the code that is the use of blue
body is always a layout though you agree
so again this is this is probably still
the one thing that's left on there what
to do about syntax currently we don't
support break and continue but as dave
ungar explained loudly several times at
the meeting i was at last week and we
already know how to do this you can
basically add an extra parameter into
the lambda which captures a closure with
a return in it so basically an exit so
if you want that you you know you put an
extra parameter in here that is e for
exit the type system such as this will
ensure that you're calling the right
thing at the right time and then you
evaluate the value of x and come out of
the loop
so yeah yes we young so that the
question of non-local exits and what
more than just Landers for control flow
we want is something that is still on
the list if lots of people say well well
well you really have to have um explicit
exits then we'll put them in you know
for quite a long time we had an explicit
loop with exit construct and then we
thought well does this mean if they
nested what happens and you have to
start naming the loops and so this is
where we're at now how are we going for
time other decisions this one I call
this one versus list too which is a kind
of a retro name basically the point here
is that variables and methods share the
same namespace so if I want a variable I
can get a variable type 3 if I want an
access a method I can just return that
variable if I want to set a method i
define a method with a slightly odd name
and it can set the variable but in fact
you don't need to do this because in
grace well the my X Y variable is
accessible as if it was defined by a
method called X that read the variable
and a method called my x colon equals
that sets the variable okay so this is
at this point setting aside issues of
encapsulation and private and protected
we know we're going to have to deal with
that the design isn't finished there yet
so one advantage this has over languages
like Java and I guess C sharp is that
you know people don't have to write the
access methods we don't have to add
extra mechanism into the language to
generate the accessor methods if you
want them and we can have the advantages
of them relatively lightweight without
you know having to add other features to
the language like attributes where you
can override the getter and setter on
the variable if you want we just have
methods we have variables
and here's one of the examples if you
like the technical theme of the talk
which is the way some of these decisions
then flow through so if for example self
was required to be explicit on every
message send like in Python and if you
require parenthesis you know to square
the variable X you have to write
something like this okay which well
looks but ugly and messy and we want to
write this ok so this decision saying
all right weird you know some level this
decision we're going to have a single
namespace for methods and variables a
field basically is something that can be
accessed by two methods means that it
then flows on to have issues for the
syntax yeah first class members we can't
have personal ok Steve anymore other for
the method x
right that's right mmmm oh no but where
do I get there go on can we hang on and
I think there's an yeah I'm going to so
yeah that's that's one place that comes
back to bite us types we're gonna have
types this thing clearly creates a
variable called Gerald and explicitly
gives it the type person this one down
here sets a variable called Gerald and
puts person into it but this one
probably should be dynamic of times so
unlike c-sharp we don't think we can ask
people to write dynamic on dynamically
type variables why because the whole
rationale for having the dynamically
typing in the first place is so that
initial students can come in and can get
their programs going you know with as
little bugginess and as little syntax as
possible so we don't want to say by the
way you declare a variable called gel by
you have to type column dynamic why do
you have to take collin dynamic you just
have to pray to the big god of the
compiler will the big god of the ide so
our current line is that in grace names
must be declared so this is unlike
python where you can magically create
new fields from a misspelling misspelt
assignment you know there's however many
years of software engineering i think
still teaches us that being able to
implicitly create fields and variables
is a bad idea in grace types can be
omitted and they may be dynamic or they
may be inferred and that looks like
being conflict sensitive and again we'll
have to see how well that works I mean
our eyes are getting used to this so we
write stuff and we think I yeah this is
all how it should work and let me try
and implement it and find out it doesn't
but this kind of choice here now this is
different from Scala where types may be
admitted but the rule is the compiler
always will attempt to infer types it
never goes Scarlett never goes to type
dynamic which means Scala always at
least has the compilers idea of what the
static type of any particular expression
is okay in grace that's not the case and
so the question you know here is what
should this do
you know should this create a
dynamically type variable and stick
person into it should this locally infer
and you know that's something we're
still debating I probably think well
locally in fur and the hopes that
generally people aren't going to be in a
situation where they're initializing a
local variable with are something that
is you know a very specific type and
then you're going to want to reassign to
a more general time but you know we'll
have to see so make the behavior of the
rest of it different weather and choose
so that's one good thing this is where
that one true message send rule comes in
the behavior of the code won't be
different but the behavior of whether
whether the program is a legal program
or not will be different that's why we
throw it overloading that's right so in
that sense well there's Gila trout that
talks about the condition that program
execution should not depend on static
types okay and the point here is we
actually go one further than that which
is that pausing can't depend on static
types all right and this is this is
where your point comes in because
whenever we see an expression we have to
be able to pass it let's skip that that
was mostly a descriptive why it's hard
where is it let's skip on skip on this
is no I'm completely lost I'm sorry he's
going to look good on the video seeing
all the slide right so this this comes
to a point about methods which is we
need to be able to decide that purely
syntactically and basically we card this
was just some other hard cases for the
type system you know as and discussion
with mad stuff yesterday you know what
should 3 + cucumber new you do is this a
static type error or do we magically
decide that somehow it's being done
amateur time right so yes the good thing
is is that if this expression is formed
there will be a sensible execution and
that's an important property there's
still a question of whether we decide to
signal a type error for this or not and
at some point I say and what happens
with that type error is really up to the
up to the programming environment well
what I think we need to do is we plan to
do is define the language so that there
is a type system and this would presume
and I guess on the most time-efficient
we can think of unless for some reason
cucumber new is returning something of
type dynamic this would give a static
type error or it would be an error in
terms of the type system right now
because the one true method send rule
and the cause of this decoupling yes
there is a sensible syntax and yes you
could go and run there and get
syntactically correct and at some point
this now comes up to these options about
pedagogy just because you could sensibly
run the program doesn't mean that an
instructor might want you to run the
program they won't want you to get
everything type so first ok Martin
Renard has a nice project called ductile
J which you know provides this for java
he's basically going through and
effectively adding stuff into the java
compiler so that you know basically
anything that's half syntactically
correct will compile and can be run by
pushing all the tests off to run time
this is another one here you know if you
have a method in your api called draw
string of list figure and you make a
list of objects and stick figures into
it you know can you pass it in here ok
and this thin this relates to the
dimensions of how much and how deep you
know your dynamic type checking is if
you do an eager type check presumably
you will just say well look list of
figure is sorry list of object it's not
compatible with us to figure so even if
this stuff is all dynamic actually that
one is static so this could give a
static type error here even if we made
this dynamic then presumably we could
get a dynamic type error here even
though everything in the list is the
figure and you know this is actually a
question that we are literally thinking
about right now happy for suggestions if
we say okay you want to deal with real
typed AP is then you know you just have
to remember the right list figure in
here there won't be any other type
checking but you'll get dynamic type
errors which will be really easy to
explain you know ups you made a list of
object and its list
figure and at some point you'll have to
get the idea that well because in grace
like an c sharp in there and the.net
languages the generics are really
rarified you have to have the right
generics in the right places okay there
are other options those other options
are more complicated one is which i
think the DLR will certain cases do is
you do something to actually kind of
turn your list of object into a list of
figure by changing the generic in such a
way that every time you access a figure
you check that it is I figure all you
throw exception or something even for
later dynamically rather than checking
hard on the boundary here and type
racket I think does something similar in
these circumstances but they can be even
more flexible these are open questions I
think still about language design that
we are struggling with and I think in
manuals point there that we do have a
semantics for this we can run things we
want to is important to mine a point so
this is the slide about blocks which you
all wish we should have had earlier so
again this is a design decision that
comes right out of the small talk
tradition of languages anything in curly
brackets is a block so the
distinguishing syntax for block is not
the arrow like it is in Scala or I think
C sharp it's the curly brackets and you
can think of this as defining our method
called apply which just an object with a
single method called apply which has
this and runs it okay and you call it
like that
and so this is the ambiguity we were
talking about you have to write block
dot apply here because if you're able to
write something like that or with no
arguments like this you know what are
you doing are you are you calling a
method that returns a block which you
can do you know you can have a variable
of type block you can store a block into
it and you call block and out it comes
well when does it run in this case it
runs when you send apply okay there are
stuff we can do statically even in the
dynamic type language that's what this
was about so if someone does this or if
they write while with the blacks brought
with the brackets in the wrong place
we're hoping that statically we will be
able to provide useful error messages
about this you know if then is the fault
will be defined on self or somewhere
lexical it always be a definition in
scope that will say this thing needs a
block well I'm not passing in a block
I'll at least get a static error there
or maybe if you've got you know treat
all static errors warnings I'll get a
static warning and then you run it and
then you'll get whatever print through
print three will happen and then this
thing will try and send apply to it and
you'll get a message that says doesn't
understand apply
for those of you who are hardcore sorry
so you have this blocks which are
physically anonymous function yep but i
cannot refer to the actual gain function
to use it in place of law so you always
have to edit converter
right so what you'll have to do is use
the block syntax and just define a block
that takes arguments and feeds them in
it yeah yeah yeah well that's good
enough and again that's the small talk
I'm showing through and you know the
answer is all we can add in one extra
bit of syntax which will have to be a
magic syntax but precisely because this
is saying you can't do it in the
standard syntax but i think vb has the
same problem it's this according to mads
and so you have he has an address of
operator i'm not sure what it's called
that you can apply to a method and and
get either thing in one of the earlier
designs I put that in I think it's going
to be FN so you just write FN be and
that will get a you know the way we
explain it is this will get you this
block which we can write down like this
it's just shorthand scholar of course
uses the underscore so in scala method
name underscore rare flies it it has
exactly the same problem and you know it
keeps its complexity countdown by using
underscore for a large number of
different things in the language design
and let's just say that one was kind of
non obvious but there are even more fun
things that scholar does with you know
that scholar has several different
solutions to this problem but actually
has exactly the same problem and you
know again this is a case where you know
aiming at different audiences the two
languages are making different choices
and we think that you know having an
explicit apply that you have to write I
mean there's some code doing fairly
hairy stuff with blocks and if you you
know if you're the kind of person who
likes the untyped lambda calculus this
is the encoding of if more or less from
the untyped lambda calculus and then
we'll have methods on this will be a
boolean and it understands method if
true else and you know it takes those
blocks and it just does apply while loop
standard tail-recursive while loop how
much is writing that going to basically
put people off the whole idea of using
the language or we don't know we'll have
to see
occasionally we're kicking around other
ideas for other syntaxes like this but I
at this point I'm still keen on being on
this one how are we going so here's some
examples of things will be backed off
well here's one example of something we
backed off the original version of
language said yeah yeah yeah let's just
put everything in from every language
that everybody likes and everybody likes
Python right and Python syntax so we'll
have syntax like this and you know not
only are we doing semicolon removal or
inference how we want to call it or
insertion we're also doing block
insertion okay so somehow the tabbing
will tell you this is a while we are in
the middle of a method and this isn't
just an argument this is an argument
that needs to be in curly brackets how
remembering want to do this without
necessarily having any static type
information I don't know by counting the
number of spaces maybe if it's if it's
even you could put the brackets around
here and if it's all she couldn't and I
had convinced myself that it was
possible to have an algorithm to do this
and then spend several hours on a plane
trying to write it out and left the
notebook in the transit lounge in LA in
February and yeah we think this is
probably an idea whose time went about
the same time that we thought it up
because while it might be nice to do
this having these explicit blocks in
order to explain what a while statement
is doing and you know as Andrew Beck
says well these braces you know we think
of them as suspenders because they
suspend the computation makes things
explicit and you know this kind of magic
well was that went in that went out but
we're still going to have a Python like
rule which says its syntax error if the
indentation that you actually have is
inconsistent with your bracketing okay
so if you start everything in the
left-hand column not a problem if you
put the brackets in here and laid it out
with brackets not a problem but if you
left out the brackets and wrote you know
if you put the bracket soon and then
move this thing out far to the left hand
side you
get an error saying the bracketing being
being done in consistently we don't know
how confusing that's going to be for
people but you know we're at least going
to run with that and see how it goes
here's another one Ruby and Python and
what does this code do ABCD can we write
it what would it do could do lots of
things you know this is in some way the
small talk interpretation ABCD so send a
method d to c and then you said that i
give in you send a to self you sent beta
phase and cedar beams and d to c which
is this one scholar at least one version
of grace where we tried to get rid of
the parentheses by saying every argument
is you know our every function takes one
argument which is actually fortresses
rule every function only ever takes one
argument you want more than one argument
you pass a couple I think ml might
technically do the same thing okay so we
do that and in which case the
interpretation of this is this which is
kind of odd for a more object-oriented
language especially when two out of the
three people have enough small talk
smarts to always read it as this so the
current compromise and it is a
compromise because again it's it's a
learning language is um you can with the
parentheses when there's one argument
and when that arguments are literal but
otherwise you put the parentheses in so
you can write print hello world and
we'll probably put some kind of
insertion syntax here so that you know
beginning programmers can write for it a
plus B equals C and just by inserting
stuff into the string and it's important
it's clearly important for control
structures that you want to be able to
put in these blocks without parentheses
in them and you know following groovy
its would not be inconsistent to allow
you to have if we wanted to go to the
standard if a while syntax it's not
inconsistent to say ok you'll just write
a block and that you have an expression
and a block and then another block and
an expression and they don't have to all
then I cells be being another
parenthesis
first I labware wouldn't be inconsistent
but it's not a great rule but we think
it captures most of the common cases
here but the other side is um it once
again tries to make things simple and
tries to remove him and the guilty and
what in what people write them and what
it's likely to do so what time should I
yea sorry that's repressions one is what
kind of us are you ready to read this
syntax and I assume there probably won't
be that first pot of plastic
after the CSU class and second bushes
what kind of contracts you have for
apparels good both were questions so the
answer is this parlor is straightforward
and what kind of part is we write and we
do that various people are doing
implementation so one thing that's
different about the grace project is
we're not trying to produce the one best
product at least not at this point it's
you know the old 1960s strange idea that
where you want a specification for one
of these things and then you have
implementations of the specification
they're actually different so I know
that Andrew black has a I think they're
at least two parcels that have been done
with pazzo combinators one in small talk
and one in scarlet and I've got a
student who's working in lv m and he now
has a slightly bootstrap sort of mini
version of grace written in itself so i
presume he's just using a recursive
descent parser but you know if you're
familiar with small talk you know this
syntax is very similar in spirit to
Smalltalk syntax you can posit recursive
descent you can you know it's much we
think because of keywords are in the
right place and and because there isn't
this issue of you know names which can
be used to find being used to indicate
syntactic categories that you have for
example in C++ so once you defend
something as a class you can just use it
and it creates new synthetic category
and you know the kind of things talked
about before that the parts of this can
be done by a student in their notebook
without having to know the static x and
you know we think this is good it's you
know I could imagine giving students
exercises which say here is a line draw
a parse tree okay now that's quite as
that's you know for most expressions
this will just be relatively
straightforward but I wouldn't really
want to do that in Java because first of
all you'd have to memorize 20 different
operator precedence a--'s and then if
you said okay go on and explain how this
little bit of Java is executed and
there's some message sense that are
overloaded I mean
yes it's good to do this because it
makes programming hard and this means
that people who aren't very good will
fail but yeah so so um currently I do I
little currently the spec says that plus
and times and you know- and divide have
the usual precedence above all other
operators all other operators have the
same precedence and you must prevent the
size and it's sorry all operas have the
same prisoners it's assumed that they
associate watch the left and I mean to
the left it's assumed they associate and
there's no precedence so this is
basically the rule from self which which
I particularly liked which says that if
you want to have different operators you
haven't you must parenthesis and other
than that you know if you write a plus B
plus C it means exactly the same as a
dot M open paren BM open paren see close
close so
okay so there's a few other slides
mostly with jokes this one was my last
attempt at booking a ticket on the
Eurostar with a credit card off issued
in New Zealand we're doing the obvious
stuff to get rid of no pointer errors
not having an ill having ways of putting
in non little type null types if you
really want null and probably having a
special uninitialized value and it's
always an exception to access an
uninitialized field one thing I haven't
talked about and won't talk about in any
real detail as how to clear objects and
classes I've mainly put these slides in
because some people said the last time I
gave the talk I thought that Andrew
black and I were talking about
completely different languages we're not
I've mostly been talking about the
message syntax inside methods but we
will have object constructors that you
can run to construct objects funnily
enough we'll have classes which
basically take the parameter for one
constructor method that you used to
create lots of classes and there is in
fact an encoding or at least an
explanation of classes in terms of
objects and the important thing from a
software point of view he engineering
point of view here is that the method
new applied to some class is not a
special thing in the language and that
you know there isn't a static side and a
dynamic side to things like there is in
MC sharp or in Java you know you create
an object by a normal method if you want
to substitute something in there if you
want to build factory objects you can go
right ahead I'll leave this service was
the obscure part of pattern matching so
again following new speaking scholar
will have a pattern match construct that
will basically work inside methods in
the language we won't allow clause or
method definitions and this was briefly
how it was designed using message sense
in a ways
what are you currently doing well in
some sense we think we've mostly
finished the issue of designing stuff
inside methods the one big question
there is you know do we really need
something more with control flow do we
have to have call cc or something
question of type structural and nominal
or structural versus nominal originally
we all agreed on it being structural
types and then we've had two
conversations with Gil our bra has so
far had lots of experience with doing
real programming with structural types
in New speak and basically said well the
problem is the error messages would get
a completely rubbish you know some type
which is a parameter of this structural
type which has this form doesn't match
this other type which is a structure of
this form on a parameter here somewhere
else so we're thinking about this this
issue again I've talked about how do you
actually match the static and dynamic
types where do you decide to use type
inference how much does this matter and
modules encapsulation
so in some sense this is the other some
of the other stuff that we're not
planning to put in particular language
features but I suppose you could say
what we're trying to do is clear a space
so that these can be added in as
language extensions are absolutely
necessary but you know one of the goals
of this project is to see how far you
can get when we leave the only language
extension message you have is libraries
is being able to pass in blocks as
arguments you know we don't have a tower
of macroalgae like you might have scheme
and this is the answer to the question
parallelism concurrency what we have
done so far is get it all out of the
language so you don't have weight
statements you don't have locks on every
object the question then is ok how do
you get it back in again and now all I
can say is it's on the list and once
we've got the next stage done where we
have some idea of the way the module
systems will work one of the things that
you know I'm certainly going to want to
do is at least start sketching out how
various forms of parallelism you know
could be defined in this sort of way I
mean we've got blocks that full
statement just takes a block so clearly
being able to run parallel accumulates
and parallel map reduces and stuff off
collections is at least going to be
syntactically easy to express whether we
can do the kind of stuff that fortress
does you know with splitting and merging
and more complicated analysis i'm not
sure but we'll have to see then we can
manage answer before you even start
comparisons that
it's not in there good do javascript
brought up so funny
so um whoops we'll leave that that
that's right the main point we're sorry
I have to in my defense i'll say i
usually use powerpoint we're not done
yet and so one of the things i keep
saying and really is true is that one of
the reasons i want to be here today and
want to give this talk is because you
know we want to know what you think we
want to know what tracks we shouldn't
fall into so so far i've been assuming
that we don't know nate javas mistake
that will go on ask doug lee and bilk
you what we should do I talked to the x
10 people talk for the fortress people
and that's what we plan to do and at
this point the question really is is you
know are there any decisions we've made
thus far which are committing us to
something in the memory model which is
going to come back to bite us later and
you know so far we've been saying we're
designing the syntactic syntax I'm
looking out how to do the basic stuff I
don't think there's anything there which
will bite us but now if we really need
call cc or we really already need to be
thinking about some of these things we
hope that the language surface syntax
will be flexible enough that you can
express software transactional memory if
that's what you want to do if you want
to do traditional java or c sharp style
locks on objects and synchronized
statements and synchronized methods
you'll be able to declare those in a
library and metadata and they'll go in
nicely and then of course there's the
issue of how do you execute all these
things underneath the idea very much is
to teach a core language that can
relatively easily be pushed into these
areas so that you know if in a second
half of first semester you know instead
of using the time to teach people the
difference between java syntax and
Python syntax you could actually use it
to say oh by the way for the last couple
of weeks we're going to be looking at
some of these issues with parallel
algorithms and his STM and you just
write atomic or something and and off
you go yeah
applications from popular courses have
you implemented or try to write down in
Prince so like MIT Python course has a
bunch of game things can you write that
game right at this stage we haven't run
the village shows us to trim yes I could
dancers to see like oh yes yes so again
I think Kim Bruce has a couple of
students that he's got interns working
for him over the summer and I know that
one of them is going through his course
material which i think is basically data
structures Corson I'm trying to get
those into grace and that would be
interesting exercise because I think
they're originally done in Scala and so
he's probably knows integrates but yes
doing that kind of thing doing the basic
hello worlds doing yeah that's probably
a very good stuff how to design programs
for something else we're going to go
after yeah experiencia showing us to an
experienced programmers that we've seen
what are they react error messages
No
I might wonder if that would feed back
into the language
well we hope that it will but we're
trying to get somewhere first and the
other issue is at this point um we're
looking at doing it so this is this is
again in the same way as multiple
pedagogy geez at this point we're trying
to define a language and not just to
find an environment so we can say we'd
want something like processing we want
something like Blue Jay would want the
Eclipse plug-in ideally would want a
visual studio plugin but where was it
you know in as much as this is a serious
project the timescale for those things
is you know three years in the future it
is a big favor get your whole course yes
it is good don't you people program so
that this is this stuff we can do their
server versions local sessions have you
already made
practicality in terms of you know not
having to reimplement olive win32 or.net
what your next in line put this in front
of the classroom so that you don't have
to figure out this libraries right so
again library design is something I'm
looking forward to getting on to
probably next year when we've got an
idea about what the module mechanisms
that would let us talk to libraries will
be one thing that we put in the language
was stolen shamelessly from F sharp
which is the backtick identifier so we
will at least be able to write the
identifiers to talk to dotnet libraries
and maybe if necessary you could have a
function then metadata annotation that
says look in net this really is
something else but our name has to be
different because we're not overloaded
and the.net thing depends on being
overloaded that's as far as we've gone I
think the whole issue of library design
is both important and really hard it's
particularly hard because at this point
we haven't made a decision that we're
going to stick to one platform and
certainly one of the big advantages of
scholar and one place where that differs
from grace's they said right well an F
sharp I mean they both made similar
decisions on different platforms we're
going to cleave tightly to the model of
a particular platform and this means
they you know have got overloading and
they've got to deal with the message
semantics and I've got to deal with the
object model when in many cases you get
the feeling that rather not at this
point we're saying well we're really not
rather not we'd really math not say if
you're on the if you're on the JVM the
gen-x not rarified you know or if you're
on either one of these you have to deal
with overloading and we lied to you
early on which is what you know fine
you'll be interesting to see how long
that one holds up visit languages that
have four arguments
that's notebooks
I terms of performance is it is it
something that
my way when you don't
are you not walking into something
that's just never going to performers
so if you've got really good compiler
and vm people like craig chains and
litter slay then you know you can go
faster than java well you could twenty
years ago slight i mean it's like more
obvious thing is well we can do what
small talk does which is basically or
you're extending from grace dot standard
environment and you know these are
messages on self and we statically know
that whip or you know this may in fact
be in the lexical chain and we
statically know that this if is the one
that was defined in it because its final
and it hasn't been redefined and our
compiler can see that okay so I mean
that's the that's what squeak does and
that's what that's what sweet does
that's what small hooks generally do and
it's fine and once again there's a
different you know there's this
difference between the language and
implementation you get into issues with
this because one thing we say is why
we're not necessarily interested in raw
performance we are interested in having
a consistent performance model and a
performance model where other as if and
if you really want to you can define it
yourself in your program runs 20 times
slower is not really great so what do
you do but the transition for students
complete this and now they're not
transitioning this job with director
transition julissa vos password
it's necessary going average like you
want to see
which is all but how do you one of the
challenges do you think in the design of
this language that will show up when you
try to transition to something Maxie so
our hope is that it will be no worse
than Java really under that that's what
we can say and as much as possible we're
doing things to at least yet get get
people Zion if that makes sense so this
is where you know the the language the
method I showed up is not trying to be a
million miles away from the sort of Java
C C++ style as a keyword class there's a
class named there's curly brackets or
assignments that look pretty much like
assignments and so it goes and we hope
that people whose you know I get get
some facility at reading grace will be
able to move and reed sea or the
languages in you know what Ward
Cunningham calls the curly bracket
family without much trouble you know the
answer is we won't really know until
what has been less been out there for a
while but wondering about which are no
good surprises you're not happy need us
used to do you want
when it complies
oh well hopefully prototype
implementations is this year so and you
know it's what it's in the middle of the
year and we already have some prototype
implementations you know on one side I
think you know one of the reasons why
this is feasible to be done at this
point without you know vast amounts of
institutional support from somewhere
although if anybody has institutional
support where with quite happy to accept
it gratefully is you know when you look
at stuff like you know that there's this
tooling so you know our net there's
visual studio and there's a bunch of
other things that let you put together
languages quickly and I mean the speed
at which you've been able to put Daphne
in various things together and that
other people have done so means well
this doesn't have to take years on the
other side we're working with students
the language spec is going to presumably
be reasonably fluid and it is fluid now
for a while and I think we're aware of
the difference between a prototype
implementation that works for research
and something that would be happy to put
in front of students come from computer
science for they learn Java what do you
think you need to unteach
or have them unlearn in order to be
successful in Greece
well that will have to tell them to put
Colin's before the equals sign for
assignment and spell out type names with
uppercase letters always important do
semantics why don't we know how bad
moral AP Computer Sciences but I'm
hoping it it's basically you know that
semantic model should hold I mean you
know what's the argument in your
argument that well you can switch from
Java to see if you're a Java programmer
you can switch to c-sharp by just
changing the syntax I don't know whether
that's probably not true anymore there's
now a lot more in c-sharp than there is
in Java but to a first approximation i
would guess the distance is roughly the
same i'm so getting talkin thank you for
your five